This is 99% invisible. I am Roman Mars. Let's start with some Pittsburgh humor. This is comedian Tom Usual on WDVE in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. It's my dad's birthday a few weeks ago and I thought you know what, I'm going to get something really nice for my dad, something he's really going to like. So I got him this GPS system, you know, are those nice ones with the sexy voice that talks to you while you're driving. Right. I'm like, he's going to love this. Tom's dad, a lifelong Pittsburgher, couldn't make heads nor tails of the GPS's directions because I am told no one in Pittsburgh actually calls anything by its official name. It's not Interstate 376, it's the parkway, it's not the Liberty tunnel, it's the tubes.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。让我们先从匹兹堡的幽默开始。这是喜剧演员汤姆·尤苏尔（Tom Usual）在宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的WDVE电台上的表演。几周前是我爸爸的生日，我想，你知道吗，我要给爸爸买点特别好的东西，他一定会喜欢的。所以我给他买了这套GPS导航系统，你知道的，就是那种带有性感语音，在你开车时会跟你说话的高级货。没错。我想，他一定会爱死这个的。汤姆的父亲是一位地道的匹兹堡人，他完全听不懂GPS的导航指令，因为据我所知，匹兹堡没有人会用官方名称来称呼任何地方。那不是376号州际公路，那是“公园大道”（the parkway）；那不是自由隧道（Liberty tunnel），那是“管道”（the tubes）。
So the joke goes, looking to help his dad out, Tom downloaded a special plug-in that makes the GPS device give directions like a Pittsburgher. Get on a parkway going towards Tom. Get off like you're going to Canny Woods, where you're going up a hill under a railroad track and you're making a left and a right the same time. Go pass that crazy church up there on stilts. Make a right and if you go pass where Swissville high school used to be you went too far. Where used to be? Yeah, you have to know where stuff used to be.
所以笑话是这样的，为了帮他爸爸，汤姆下载了一个特殊的插件，让GPS设备能像匹兹堡人一样给出导航指令。上公园大道往汤姆方向走。在你要去坎尼伍兹（Canny Woods）的地方下路，你要爬上一座山，穿过一条铁轨，然后同时向左和向右转。经过上面那个建在支柱上的疯狂教堂。向右转，如果你经过了以前瑞士谷（Swissville）高中所在的地方，你就走过头了。以前所在的地方？是的，你得知道东西以前在哪里。
Otherwise you're in trouble. Sometimes the stories of what used to be can have more meaning than what's actually here now. The philosopher Guy de Bohr had a word for using your emotions and memories as a way of way finding. He called it psychogiography. That's the philosopher Sam Greenspan. And psychogiography is particularly useful in Pittsburgh. So we passed Bob's diner. Bob's diner that we just passed used to be a car dealership. And I
否则你就麻烦了。有时，关于“过去是什么”的故事比“现在是什么”更有意义。哲学家居伊·德波（Guy Debord）曾用一个词来描述利用情感和记忆作为寻路方式。他称之为“心理地理学”（psychogeography）。这是哲学家萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）的观点。而心理地理学在匹兹堡特别有用。所以我们经过了鲍勃餐馆（Bob's diner）。我们刚刚经过的鲍勃餐馆以前是一家汽车经销商。而我
know that because it was a car dealership when I first moved to this area. And then the family dollar across the street there used to be a grocery store. And I don't know that one first hand. That's just all through here, say. This is Pittsburgh resident Mike Neilsson. This place is just right with things that used to be things. It's like it's kind of like history, you know. It's not history like George Washington and the whiskey rebellion, but this stuff is, it's our history. Mike is not from Pittsburgh. He grew up on the other side of the state.
知道这一点，是因为我刚搬到这个地区时，它还是一家汽车经销商。街对面的家庭美元商店（Family Dollar）以前是一家杂货店。我不是亲眼所见，那只是道听途说。这是匹兹堡居民迈克·尼尔森（Mike Neilsson）。这个地方到处都是“曾经是某某东西”的东西。这就像是历史，你知道的。这不是乔治·华盛顿和威士忌暴乱那种历史，但这些东西，这是我们的历史。迈克不是匹兹堡人。他在州的那一头长大。
So when he moved there, he had a hard time figuring out how to get around. Because Pittsburghers are always telling him to turn left at something that isn't there anymore. And so one day Mike was hanging out with his buddy Tom. That is Tom Usual, the comedian from a minute ago. Tom was trying out the Pittsburgher GPS routine on Mike. As he kind of told it different ways, it was normally where there used to be that gas station or where there used to be that Italian restaurant. And you'd say, yeah, that's kind of funny.
所以当他搬到这里时，他很难搞清楚怎么绕路。因为匹兹堡人总是告诉他在某个已经不存在的东西那里左转。所以有一天，迈克和他的好友汤姆在一起。就是刚才提到的喜剧演员汤姆·尤苏尔。汤姆正在对迈克尝试那个“匹兹堡人GPS”的段子。当他以不同的方式讲述时，通常是“在以前那个加油站所在的地方”或者“在以前那家意大利餐厅所在的地方”。你会说，是的，那挺好笑的。
But I think in one telling of the joke or somewhere along the line He said something about you know, oh, yeah, where there used to be that pizza hut The light went off in my head I said ah, yes the pizza hut for Mike the former pizza hut was a beacon of light Shining through a thick fog of impossible directions Because here in his friend's comedy routine, was the one Pittsburgh-East direction he could give that anyone, regardless of where they're from, could comprehend.
但我认为在讲这个笑话的某次过程中，或者在某个环节，他说了一些关于“哦，是的，在以前那家必胜客（Pizza Hut）所在的地方”。我脑子里突然灵光一现，我说，啊，是的，必胜客。对于迈克来说，那家前必胜客是一座灯塔，照亮了那团令人抓狂的导航迷雾。因为在他朋友的喜剧段子里，这是他能给出的唯一一个匹兹堡东部的方向，无论来自哪里的人都能听懂。
Ten left at the place that used to be a pizza hut. There are two hallmarks of pizza hut architecture. One, the whole thing is built at a trap zoids. The windows are trap zoids, and they're framed by this kind of trapezoidal paneling on the exterior. If you remember your geometry, you know that trapezoid is a four-sided figure with two parallel sides and two non-parallel sides. It tends to look like a triangle with a top chopped off. If you see the trapezoid windows, then you know it's an old pizza hut. And then there's the roof, which often has oversized trapezoidal awnings, and where they all connect to the top is this big hump that just shoots into the air.
在以前是必胜客的地方左转。必胜客的建筑有两个标志性特征。第一，整个建筑是梯形的。窗户是梯形的，外面由这种梯形镶板框起来。如果你还记得几何知识，你知道梯形是一个有两条平行边和两条非平行边的四边形。它看起来像一个切掉了顶部的三角形。如果你看到梯形窗户，你就知道那是一家老必胜客。然后是屋顶，通常有超大的梯形遮阳篷，它们在顶部连接的地方是一个直接冲向天空的大驼峰。
The whole thing looks like a lid for the building, or a hat. Actually, when I was a kid, I thought, a hut and hat meant the same thing. Thank you, Pizza Hut. Now Pizza Hut's don't all look like this. Franchise owners have a lot of freedom in how their stores look. Now, the Reap Pizza Hut has the lid roof and the trapezoid features, and some might be more distinctive than others, but there's still enough commonality in pizza huts
整个东西看起来像建筑的盖子，或者一顶帽子。其实我小时候以为“Hut”（小屋）和“Hat”（帽子）是一个意思。谢谢你，必胜客。现在，必胜客并不都长这样。加盟商在店面外观上有很大的自由度。现在，必胜客确实有盖子屋顶和梯形特征，有些可能比其他的更具特色，但必胜客之间仍然有足够的共同点，
that once you've seen one, you can easily identify any other. In fact, the PizzaHot School of Architecture is so distinctive that even when a pizza hut goes under and gets converted into a different business, you can still totally tell it used to be a pizza hut goes under and gets converted into a different business, you can still totally tell. It used to be a pizza hut. And every town across the world, there used to be a pizza hut.
以至于一旦你见过一家，你就能轻易认出任何其他一家。事实上，必胜客的建筑风格是如此独特，以至于即使一家必胜客倒闭并被改造成其他企业，你仍然能完全看出它以前是一家必胜客。在世界各地的每个城镇，都曾经有一家必胜客。
And most of them are still standing, and most of them are not still pizza huts. And so it's this image that we just all have, and we're all so familiar with. Okay, Mike is definitely overstating it here, not every town in the world has a former pizza hut. And I couldn't get numbers on whether or not the majority of the old school trapezoidal window style pizza huts are still active pizza huts, but the fact remains, there is something really funny and a little sad, but mostly funny about seeing a former pizza hut get turned into something else.
它们中的大多数仍然屹立不倒，但大多数已经不再是必胜客了。所以这是我们大家都拥有的形象，我们都非常熟悉。好吧，迈克在这里绝对是夸大其词了，并不是世界上每个城镇都有前必胜客。我也无法获得关于大多数老式梯形窗风格的必胜客是否仍然是活跃的必胜客的数据，但事实仍然是，看到一家前必胜客被改造成其他东西，确实有些非常有趣，甚至有点悲伤，但主要是好笑。
The satirical newspaper The Onion Thoughts O2, they once had a headline that read, you can tell Area Bank used to be a pizza hut. If The Onion thinks it's funny too, I'm validated. And so Mike Nielsen did the only logical thing to do when you get obsessed with something. He started a blog. And his blog is called It Used to Be a Pizza Hut,
讽刺报纸《洋葱报》（The Onion）曾有一个标题写道：“你可以看出某地银行以前是一家必胜客”。如果《洋葱报》也觉得这很有趣，那我就被证实了。所以迈克·尼尔森在痴迷于某件事时做了唯一合乎逻辑的事情。他开了一个博客。他的博客叫“它曾经是一家必胜客”（It Used to Be a Pizza Hut），
which is a blog about the current uses of former pizza huts. It is a global atlas of buildings that used to be pizza huts. I can't defend it, so I'll just go ahead and say, yep, that's what I've been doing with some of my spare time. He even coined a word for them. I guess they're upbaths. You know, what you get when you abbreviate used to be a pizza hut, UTBAPH.
这是一个关于前必胜客当前用途的博客。它是曾经是必胜客的建筑的全球地图集。我无法为它辩护，所以我直接说，是的，这就是我用业余时间做的事情。他甚至为它们创造了一个词。我想它们是“Upbaths”。你知道的，缩写“Used to be a pizza hut”就是UTBAPH。
Though, I don't think Mike had ever said it out loud. Upbath, does that sound right? A bath. I mean that sounds horrendous, but I guess that's just what it spells out to be. I should have done a better background in it. I should have thought of something that would spell out something really cool. Mike started documenting a baths around Pennsylvania, like that pocket pond in North for sales, with its trapezoidal windows done up in a kind of sea foam green
虽然我不认为迈克曾经大声说出来过。“Upbath”，听起来对吗？“A bath”（洗澡）。我的意思是这听起来很糟糕，但我猜这就是它拼写出来的样子。我本应该做更好的背景调查。我本应该想出一个能拼出很酷单词的东西。迈克开始记录宾夕法尼亚州周围的“Upbaths”，比如北凡尔赛（North Versailles）那个口袋池塘，它的梯形窗户被漆成了一种海泡绿色，
with yellow trim. Pretty soon, he started getting submissions from across the US, and from Australia and New Zealand. Through this data set, Mike was able to chart some trends. Sometimes there's still pizza restaurants, which I think makes sense too. They probably had pizza ovens in them that maybe stuck around. There's sopranos, pizzeria, and york, Pennsylvania, and la portchetta, and auclin, New Zealand. There are evenanos pizzeria in York, Pennsylvania, and La Portetta in Auckland, New Zealand. There are even cases of Domino's pizza moving into Uttbafs. The gall. And then there's a class of non-pizzer restaurants.
配上黄色饰边。很快，他开始收到来自美国各地，以及澳大利亚和新西兰的投稿。通过这个数据集，迈克能够绘制出一些趋势。有时它们仍然是披萨店，我觉得这也说得通。它们可能保留了披萨烤箱。在宾夕法尼亚州约克市有“Sopranos Pizzeria”，在新西兰奥克兰有“La Porchetta”。甚至还有多米诺披萨（Domino's）搬进“Upbaths”的案例。真是厚颜无耻。然后还有一类非披萨餐厅。
Mexican and Asian restaurants, generally Chinese restaurants. Chinese Hut in Toronto, Ontario. Suvlaki Hut in Dandenong Australia. The structures that housed these businesses all began life unmistakably as pizza huts. But there are some more interesting ones. I think one of the most popular posts on the blog is the Des Moines Police Traffic Unit. On that entry, Mike writes, and I quote, all the cops week after week that if they don't get their act together and get traffic violations under
墨西哥和亚洲餐厅，通常是中餐馆。多伦多安大略省的“Chinese Hut”。澳大利亚丹德农的“Souvlaki Hut”。容纳这些企业的建筑最初无疑都是必胜客。但还有一些更有趣的。我认为博客上最受欢迎的帖子之一是得梅因（Des Moines）警察交通部门。在那篇条目中，迈克写道，我引用：“所有的警察周复一周地被告知，如果他们不振作起来，控制住交通违规，他们就得去必胜客工作。”然后市长进来宣布他们确实都要在必胜客工作。证据室在冷藏库里，审讯在卡座里进行，秘书们玩着桌面吃豆人（Pac-Man）而不是玩纸牌。这就是我脑海中的画面。我喜欢它。澳大利亚有一家殡仪馆也是必胜客改建的。新南威尔士州里夫斯比（Revesby）的奥尔森殡仪馆（Olson's Funerals）。而在所有“Upbaths”中的皇冠明珠，是澳大利亚布里斯班的“Chaos Adult Concepts”，Chaos和Concepts都是以C开头。那是一家成人书店，所有的窗户都被封起来了，
control, they will have to work at a pizza hut. And then the mayor coming in and breaking the news that they would, indeed, all be working in a pizza hut. Evidence room in the cooler interrogations happening in the booths, secretaries playing table top Pac-Man instead of solitary. That is how I picture this one. And I love it. There's a funeral home in Australia that is in a form of pizza hut. Olson's Funeral's in Reavesby, New South Wales. In the crown jewel of all of Baths, Brisbane Australia's chaos adult concepts, chaos and concepts are in stock with Kays. It was an adult bookstore and it had all the windows kind of boarded up,
你知道的，成人书店通常都这样。虽然我猜大多数成人书店不需要把窗户遮盖物切成梯形。现在我应该说，迈克对必胜客并没有什么特别的偏爱。当然，他小时候去过那里，吃过个人披萨，玩过桌面吃豆人，用半透明的红色塑料杯喝过百事可乐。但这并不意味着他怀旧。
you know, as adult bookstores tend to. Though I'm guessing most adult bookstores don't have to have their window coverings cut into trapezoids. Now I should say that Mike doesn't have any particular affinity for pizza hut. Sure, he went there as a kid, ate some personal pan pizzas, played some tabletop Pac-Man, drank Pepsi out of translucent red plastic cups. But it's not like he's nostalgic.
他只是觉得“Upbaths”很有趣。我是一个很容易被逗乐的人，所以我认为这很有趣，但我认为很多事情都很有趣。但我认为这不仅仅是有趣。迈克的项目指出，很少有公司能用自己的名字来描述他们所居住的标志性的大规模生产建筑。尽管必胜客最初并没有打算让建筑成为其品牌的核心，至少起初不是。
He just thought Uttbas were funny. I'm a pretty easily amused kind of guy, and so I thought it was funny, but I think a lot of things are funny. But I think it's more than funny. Mike's project points to the fact that there just aren't too many companies whose very name describes their own signature brand of mass-produced architecture that they themselves inhabit. Although Pizza Hut never meant for architecture to be the focus of their brand, at least not at first.
必胜客成立于1958年的堪萨斯州威奇托。它实际上是由两名威奇托州立大学的学生兄弟创立的。随之而来的是，你知道的，56年后，它已发展成为全球最大的披萨公司，在世界各地拥有超过14,000家餐厅。道格·特福（Doug Turfor）是必胜客的公关总监。他说，当必胜客的创始人，弗兰克·卡尼（Frank Carney）和丹·卡尼（Dan Carney）兄弟
Pizza was founded in 1958 in Wichita, Kansas. It was actually founded by two brothers who were students at Wichita State University. And with that, you know, 56 years later, it's grown into the world's largest pizza company with more than 14,000 restaurants around the world. Doug Turfor is the public relations director of Pizza Hut. He says that when Pizza Hut's founders, the brothers Frank and Dan Carney
买下他们的第一栋建筑时，他们买了一个招牌，上面只有八个字母的空间。上面有空间写“Pizza”，但下面只有三个字符或三个字母的空间。任何拼字游戏玩家都知道，三个字母的单词其实很有限。Pizza Dad，Pizza Sad，Pizza Eel。他们看了看建筑的形状，心想，嗯，它看起来就像个小屋（Hut）。
bought their first building, they got a sign that only had room for eight letters. It had room for pizza on top, but it only had room for three characters or three letters underneath that. And any Scrabble Player knows that there are really only so many three letter words. Pizza Dad, Pizza Sad, Pizza Eel. And they kind of looked at the shape of their building and thought, well, it just kind of looks like a hut.
所以也许我们叫它“Pizza Hut”。所以如果他们有四个字母的空间，也许它会被叫作“Pizza Shed”（披萨棚）。是的，Pizza Zone，Pizza之类的。现在，最初的必胜客仍然存在，虽然不再营业。它是一个“Upbath”。它被搬到了创始人所在的现代威奇托州立大学校园里。就在他们的创业学院外面。第一家必胜客用一块牌匾纪念。如果不是那块牌匾，你根本不知道它是什么。它看起来就像个小砖房。到处都没有梯形。
So maybe we called pizza hut. So if they had four letters, maybe it would have been called pizza shed. Yeah, pizza zone, pizza, something like that. Now, the original pizza hut is still around, though not in operation. It's an up path. It's been moved to the campus of the founders on the modern Wichita State. Just outside their school of entrepreneurialism. The first pizza hut is commemorated with a plaque. And if not for that plaque, you'd have no idea what it is. It just looks like a tiny brick house. N area trapezoid anywhere.
必胜客的标志性外观是后来才有的。那是建筑师理查德·伯克（Richard Burke）的作品，他是卡尼兄弟的朋友和同学。伯克想要32,000美元的设计费。卡尼兄弟还价为每开一家必胜客支付100美元。伯克接受了，并创造了许多我们今天可以无可辩驳地识别为必胜客的特征。从那里开始，必胜客
Pizza Hut signature look came later. That was the work of an architect, a friend and classmate of the Carney brothers. A guy by the name of Richard Burke. Burke wanted $32,000 to do the design. The Carney's counter offered with $100 per Pizza Hut to subsequently open. Burke accepted and created a lot of the features that we can now recognize today irrefutably as pizza huts. And from there pizza
的建筑和他们的企业形象交织在一起。于是卡尼兄弟和他们的加盟商开始用一个又一个的小屋点缀美国大地。但在他们的鼎盛时期，必胜客无法或根本不愿想象人们不再蜂拥而至享用个人披萨或美味面包棒的时候。随着市场趋势从堂食体验转向外卖，许多必胜客关闭了。当他们的梯形窗户变暗，屋顶的驼峰在空荡荡的停车场上空升起时，就好像该公司在世界上留下了自己衰落的纪念碑。
huts architecture and their corporate image became intertwined. And so the Carnies and their franchisees began lining the American landscape with hut after hut after hut. But in their ascendancy, pizza hut couldn't or simply wouldn't imagine a time when the people would not come out in droves to enjoy a personal pan pizza or a zesty breadstick. As market trends shifted away from the dining experience and onto delivery, many pizza huts closed. And as their trapezoidal windows went dark and their roof humps rose up over empty parking lots, it was as if the company had littered the world with monuments to its own decline.
它提醒你，曾经到处都是必胜客，而现在不再有了。我们看到旧的必胜客散落在各处，就像路边的死尸。现在，必胜客的建筑遗产将提醒路人，该公司在每一个它曾经失败的地方都未能繁荣。但必胜客的道格·特福，
It reminds you that there used to be pizza huts everywhere and that there aren't anymore. We see the old pizza huts laying around, the sort of the dead carcasses along the road. And now, Pizza Hut's architectural legacy is one that will remind pastors by of the company's failure to thrive in every single place it ever failed to thrive. But Doug Turfor of Pizza Hut,
他认为“Upbaths”是一种胜利。我们为我们的业务变得如此具有辨识度而感到自豪，以至于你只要看一眼建筑就能认出来，即使它被改造成了其他东西，甚至可能再次被改造成其他东西，当你看着它时，人们知道那曾经是一家必胜客。这对我们来说真的很酷。我必须说，我想我同意道格的看法。是的，必胜客的傲慢是希腊悲剧的素材。但这并不是一个关于失败的故事。
he thinks that Udbaths are a triumph. We're pretty proud of the fact that our business became so recognizable that you can just look at a building and recognize that even as it got turned into something and then maybe even turned over into something else again, that when you just look at it, people know that used to be a Pizza Hut. That's really cool to us. I have to say, I think I'm with Doug on this one. Yes, the hubris of Pizza Hut is the stuff of Greek tragedy. But this is not a story about failure.
这是一个关于希望的故事，关于什么可以被回收，关于从一开始就无法想象的可能性。软体动物死了，寄居蟹搬进了它的壳里。但必胜客实际上正在抑制“Upbaths”的增加。在20世纪90年代末和21世纪初，公司转向了外卖和配送模式。今天，美国大约一半的必胜客在通用的玻璃盒子结构的建筑中运营。没有梯形，没有斜屋顶，它们并不显眼。事实上，我公寓附近一家新式的必胜客刚刚倒闭了。如果我从未见过它营业，我就无法知道它曾经是什么。既然我已经看到了下一代面目全非的“曾经是必胜客”，我想
It's a story about hope, about what can be reclaimed, about the possibilities for what might emerge out of what couldn't have ever been dreamed up from the outset A mollusk dies and a hermit crab moves into its shell But pizza hut is actually curbing the rise of duck baths in the late 1990s and early odds The company shifted towards a carry out and delivery model today about half the pizza huts in the US operate out of generic Glass box looking structures. No trapezoids, no sloped roofs, they don't stand out. In fact, a newer-style pizza hut near my apartment just went out of business. And if I hadn't ever seen it in operation, there'd be no way to know what it once was. Now that I've seen the next generation of faceless used to be a pizza hut, I think that
如果必胜客淘汰了他们的标志性建筑，那将是一个巨大的错误。因为必胜客在这里达到了某种伟大的程度。我的意思是，历史上还有多少其他建筑，其本质可以透过随后的任何事物闪耀出来？如果你在吉萨大金字塔里开一家汉堡店，它永远首先是吉萨大金字塔。在“曾经是大金字塔的地方”左转。
if pizza hut phases out their signature buildings, it will be a huge mistake. Because pizza hut has achieved a level of greatness here. I mean, how many other structures have there ever been in history, whose true essence can shine through whatever might come after it? If you open to hamburger joint in the great pyramid of Giza, it will always, first and foremost, be the great pyramid of Giza. And left at the place that used to be the great pyramid of Giza.
像金字塔一样，必胜客，卑微的必胜客，成功地将其身份刻在了随后的所有事物上。它达到了那个水平。必胜客设法不断提醒每个人，嘿，我曾经在这里。我就是那个有个人披萨、半透明红色塑料杯和桌面吃豆人的地方。所以让我们对强大的必胜客肃然起敬吧，它比自时光流逝以来几乎任何其他曾经深受喜爱的机构都能触及未来并宣称：试着忘记我吧。试着看看。哈，哈，哈……什么？我在塔可钟（Taco Bell）。我在必胜客和塔可钟的组合店里。
Like the pyramid, the Pizza Hut, the humble Pizza Hut, succeeds in etching its identity onto everything else that will ever come after it. It is at that level. The Pizza Hut manages to constantly remind everyone, hey, I was here. I am the place with the personal pan pizzas, with the translucent red plastic cups, with a tabletop Pac-Man. So let us stand in awe of the mighty Pizza Hut, which more than just about any other once beloved establishment since crumbled beneath the sands of time can reach into the future and proclaim. Just try and forget about me. Just try. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, What? I'm at the Taco Bell. I'm at the combination pizza hut and Taco Bell.
等等，我们在必胜客。什么？我们在塔可钟。什么？我们在必胜客和塔可钟的组合店里。我们在必胜客。我们在塔可钟。我们在必胜客和塔可钟的组合店里。我们在必胜客和塔可钟的组合店里。塔可钟。我说的不是组合必胜客，我说的不是组合必胜客……
Wait, we're at the pizza hut. What? We're at the Taco Bell. What? We're at the combination pizza hut and Taco Bell. We at the pizza hut. We at the Taco Bell. We at the combination pizza hut and Taco Bell. We're at the combination pizza hut and Taco Bell. Taco Bell. I'm not talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey,
（此处重复内容已省略）
I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey,
I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey,
（此处重复内容已省略）
I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I'm talking about combination piece of honey, I River. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arksign, a brilliant architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, Avery tweets at Troublemen. We also have a Tumblr that's really fantastic. But if you want lots more about upbaths, photos of the original Pizza Hut complete with a plaque and a completely different comedy sketch about Pittsburgh directions that also references a Pizza Hut. Go to 99pi.org.
River。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，由加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Arksign建筑事务所制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目。我在Twitter上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@SamListen，艾弗里是@Troublemen。我们还有一个非常棒的Tumblr。但如果你想了解更多关于“Upbaths”的信息，查看带有牌匾的原始必胜客的照片，以及另一个完全不同的关于匹兹堡导航的喜剧小品（也提到了必胜客），请访问99pi.org。
Radio to PO. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio to PO。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。